so hands down fasting is your absolute
best strategy
for
cancer now the diet for preventing
cancer should be different than the diet
you would be on if you
got cancer and i will discuss this in
this video now before i begin i want to
let you know that nothing in this video
is intended to replace your medical care
in fact i'm not going to make any claims
that any of this information is going to
prevent cure your cancer so i'm going to
talk about all the mechanisms of how
fasting
can greatly help you
and i want to show you something
that could greatly benefit a person
if for some reason fasting is not an
option let's say for example they're too
thin
they're too frail and they need some
other option
i'm going to show you what i would
recommend
a little later in this video
fasting is one of the oldest therapies
known to man hippocrates has talked
about the massive benefits of fasting
long ago historically nearly every
single religion practices fasting so
let's just dive right in it's very very
important to understand some differences
between normal cells and cancer cells
cancer cells originate from
normal cells what happens is this a
certain thing in your cell becomes
damaged and that thing is called the
mitochondria the mitochondria is the
energy factor of the cell it produces
all the energy for your body and so
after the mitochondria become damaged
the body through a adaptive survival
mechanism starts to switch over its
metabolism to a different way of
burning fuel
it starts to ferment
sugar and when it starts to ferment
sugar and turn into a cancer cell
it starts to become extremely hungry for
glucose now it also eats other things
which we're going to talk about but
sugar provides the most fuel for a
cancer cell in the process of a normal
cell becoming a cancer cell it also
loses its mortality in other words it
becomes immortal so your normal cells
actually have a limit they can only live
so long but the cancer cells live
forever cancer cells grow faster than
normal cells and they basically take
over the body so the first mechanism of
fasting in relationship to a cancer cell
is that fasting helps to starve off the
fuel it starves off your glucose because
guess what you're not eating anything so
no eating no glucose and so you help to
prevent feeding the cancer cell now this
was discovered by
professor otto warburg who won the nobel
prize in medicine now in extreme
conditions normal cells can temporarily
ferment sugar as in a severe infection
like sepsis or a severe
pathogen invasion in your body or in
intense exercise or trauma your body can
switch to ferment sugar so this
mechanism is a survival mechanism for
fuel all right that's mechanism one
number two
certain cancers can also live
on an amino acid called glutamine
as well as another amino acid called
arginine now the problem is glutamine
which makes up certain proteins
is very widespread it's in a lot of
different foods so when you're fast
you're not consuming glutamine
so you're going to deprive the cell
of this other fuel there are certain
therapies out there right now that are
using
medications to block glutamine and one
is called dawn which is a glutamine
inhibitor there are also natural
glutamine inhibitors as well and green
tea with its phytonutrient egcg
also has the capacity to block glutamine
creating an anti-cancer effect also
other phytonutrients in green tea are
very anti-cancer now i want to clarify
this glutamine amino acid avoiding
glutamine is not going to prevent you
from getting cancer so if you don't have
cancer you don't want to avoid glutamine
you would only want to avoid glutamine
if you had cancer so i just wanted to
make that clarification so the problem
is you can't fast forever eventually
you're going to have to eat so what type
of diet is going to limit the amount of
glutamine and
arginine because they're in a lot of
different foods well one thing you want
to do is not do a high protein diet
it's better to do a low protein diet if
you have cancer
in a moderate protein diet
if you're just trying to prevent cancer
but whey protein has a very large amount
of arginine so i would avoid any type of
protein powders especially whey protein
and nuts are also high in arginine
except for the pistachio so maybe even
more pistachios on that protocol all
right that's the protein component now
the third mechanism i want to talk about
in relationship to fasting is this
concept of autophagy you know autophagy
is not a thing it's a condition an
autophagy means self-eating it sounds
like it's something destructive but it's
something very very constructive because
it's a survival mechanism and your body
is eating up damaged
proteins
and it's recycling them
into new proteins as well as fuel so
autophagy is an alternative fuel source
and it can also degrade waste products
and it recycles damaged proteins that
you're not using anyway and it repairs
things and it cleans up things
and it has a powerful effect on cancer
it helps to shrink
tumors and it can actually inhibit
cancer development now there's different
types of autophagy one type is called
mitophagy now what is my topogene that
is autophagy for the mitochondria
so your body goes in there and it starts
to clean up
the mitochondria that are damaged
remember i talked about the cause of
cancer is damaged mitochondria well when
you fast you increase mitophagy also
autophagy is a very potent
anti-inflammatory mechanism so you're
going to drop inflammation and the thing
about inflammation is that cancer tends
to spread into
inflammation and this is why people tend
to develop cancer in areas of old injury
and areas of inflammation so it's very
very important to keep inflammation at a
minimum now this next point is very very
interesting
autophagy also cleans up carcinogens
carcinogens are those things that
promote
cancer
they can trigger cancer that would be
like pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides now radiation can also
trigger cancer but autophagy is not
going to clean up radiation now there's
another piece of this that is very very
important there are certain conditions
that
damage your ability
to perform autophagy so those things are
obesity drinking a lot of alcohol being
a diabetic
viral infections
having a fatty liver having chronic
inflammation all of these things in a
chronic nature will increase the risk of
cancer because there's less autophagy
and if you haven't guessed it the
biggest thing that triggers autophagy
is
fasting all right the next point i want
to bring up number four
is your immune system what fasting can
do to your immune system and this is
very very important to bring up because
the two main things that they do for
cancer
are chemotherapy and radiation therapy
both of these things destroy your immune
system so your immune system is really a
key factor in preventing cancer as well
as directly treating cancer your immune
system has
several mechanisms to kill cancer both
directly and indirectly so the killer t
cells can directly kill cancer cells
the helper t cells can indirectly
recruit certain white blood cells to
kill cancer and the real amazing thing
about fasting is that fasting
triggers
your immune system stem cells in your
bone marrow
to boost up your immune system and even
regrow an immune system that is damaged
and when people do radiation therapy in
chemo
adding fasting to that protocol can
decrease the side effects from radiation
and chemotherapy as well as enhance the
effectiveness
of chemo and radiation therapy now the
reason why the medical profession does
not recommend fasting in place of these
other
therapies that have side effects is
simply because they would either lose
their license or go to jail because the
way that the laws are written if you're
a medical doctor you have to practice
medicine and there's certain protocols
that you have to follow so you will
never see fasting as a primary
initial therapy it will always be used
as an adjunct to
medications now i want to touch on the
fifth mechanism
hormones there are three hormones to
briefly talk about one is called igf
number one and that's produced by the
liver that is a hormone that's very
anabolic it makes things get bigger like
muscles it also can
stimulate the growth of cancer but i
want to mention this if someone doesn't
have cancer it's not going to trigger
cancer it's only when you get cancer
that the igf number one can cause cancer
to spread so fasting decreases igf
number one the next hormone insulin okay
insulin is also an anabolic hormone
insulin has been known to increase the
risk of getting cancer and in the
presence of insulin the benefits of
fasting go way down to zero so a lot of
the benefits from fasting and autophagy
occur when the insulin is low in fact
you can't get into fasting or autophagy
without first lowering insulin so
keeping insulin low is a very very key
thing and then we have
estrogen estrogen in excess can trigger
breast cancer and cancer of the uterus
and cancer of the ovary there are
certain chemotherapies that block
estrogen production so anything that can
increase estrogen is something you want
to limit if you're trying to
treat cancer and prevent cancer like
milk you want to limit dairy if you have
cancer soy products soy is very
estrogenic especially the soy protein
isolates
birth control pills are estrogen hormone
replacement therapy has estrogen in it
so of course if you have cancer
and you're taking birth control pills
and hormone replacement therapy probably
not the best idea now iodine from sea
kelp is a wonderful natural remedy to
help balance your estrogens it's really
good for things like fibrocystic breast
or ovarian cysts and then you have dim
which is a concentrated cruciferous
product that helps to
reduce estrogen in your body and because
it comes from cruciferous it's
anti-cancer one mechanism being just
lowering the amount of estrogen all
right mechanism number six and i've
already talked about this a little bit
inflammation the more you can cut down
inflammation the less risk you have for
cancer cancer follows inflammation
a lot of people develop cancer in areas
of old injury areas of inflammation i
remember when i was in practice one lady
had
cancer in a certain part of her breast
and i asked her have you ever injured
that part of your breast
and when she thought about it she
remembered having some trauma and that
exact location another patient came in
with
cancer of the brain stem okay i asked
him if he ever injured the brain stem he
said no
but i did fall off of a roof once and i
let it in my head i said
that would be injury to your brain stem
but out of all the things that can rid
inflammation fasting is at the top of
the list and fasting also can boost the
antioxidant networks that you have in
your body thereby minimizing the free
radical damage
and lessening the damage to the
mitochondria all right now we want to
talk about the the seventh mechanism
here in relationship to fasting which
brings up this other topic
and that is ketones you now know that
cancer can live on
glucose and
two amino acids glutamine and arginine
but unfortunately ketones can provide
cancer with the cellular membrane
structure
that the cancer cell needs so in other
words just because someone's on a
ketogenic diet and they're low in sugar
does not bulletproof them from getting
cancer so
ketones
that come from fat
provide the raw material
for
the membranes around cancer cells so i
didn't know this initially this is some
new information that i
tried to suppress for for quite some
time but it kept coming up so i finally
dug into some of this research to kind
of um
accept the fact that ketones
unfortunately
can
feed the cancer some of the structural
parts that it needs even though ketones
themselves have an anti-tumor effect
okay so here's the dilemma or problem
that we're in but i'm going to give you
a solution if we can't eat carbs
and we're and we're not supposed to eat
much protein and now we can't eat fat
what the heck can we eat we can't fast
forever now i've mentioned in other
videos that i am doing some research or
supporting some research in europe
related to a non-toxic way to block
ketones and even some of you have
supported this research which you
probably have gotten an email on the
updates but this is very exciting
research and so far so good and even
though this research is being done in
mice you always start with mice before
you do human studies so this is based on
some very interesting data about cancer
cells versus normal cells
so with cancer cells
there's really only one door for ketones
to feed its membranes okay there's this
one door one chemical pathway and if
that chemical pathway was blocked you
could potentially starve off the cancer
from getting any raw material for its
membranes but the question that came up
from that is what about normal cells do
they just have one door no they don't
the membranes from normal cells can come
from fatty acids
not just ketones so the goal is to block
this door this chemical pathway
that is allowing these ketones to make
membranes for the cancer cells and this
door is called scott which stands for a
very long chemical name which i'm not
going to give you at this time and it
just happens to be
scot inhibitors okay both in the
medication area as well as using natural
things that have less side effects and
that is the area that we
are evaluating right now doing studies
in europe on mice
and so far with great success
so the following scott inhibitors are
the ones that are showing the most
promise number one we have alpha lipoic
acid number two garcinia then we have
red algae and then black seed oil and
then garlic okay garlic handles a
slightly different it's called a salvage
pathway which i'm not going to get into
now but garlic is very very important
these are all scot inhibitors that work
synergistically to help
starve the cancer
of its raw material for its cellular
membranes
now if you want more details on the
strategy
there's some additional studies which
are quite fascinating and i put those in
the description below now before i get
into the dosages i just want you know
i'm not making any claims this is going
to cure or prevent any cancer
this is a protocol that i would take if
i had cancer okay
all right alpha lipoic acid
i would start out
at .4 grams
and gradually over the course of three
weeks increase that amount to 1.8 grams
per day
now as far as garcinia i would start at
1.2 grams and gradually increase to 3
grams over a course of 3 weeks
red algae i would take eight grams per
day
black seed oil i would take 500
milligrams
twice a day
and then garlic i would take 500
milligrams
four times a day
but that would only be if i'm not
consuming actual garlic in my meals or
in other forms
so this protocol is designed to shut
that door so this pathway
called scott cannot be an option for the
cancer to get its raw material for its
membranes now another question that you
might be thinking about
the ketogenic diet increases ketones
but
fasting
also increases ketones even more than a
ketogenic diet so how can fasting help
someone with cancer if it's feeding the
cancer cell
ketones well the answer is this when you
do fasting
you also create at the same time
an epigenetic effect
way higher than the effect of just
taking ketones so there's a lot of other
things that are going on when you're
doing fasting that apparently override
this mechanism of
ketones feeding the cancer membrane
through scot
all right let's talk about the fasting
protocol there's two different protocols
one is for prevention and i'm going to
tell you right now the best thing you
can do right now is to
do whatever you can to prevent cancer
because once you get cancer
you have
the medical profession who is giving you
all this information and putting the
fear of god in you that you better do
this and you better not do this and it's
a massive confusion not to mention
friends and family giving you their two
cents
not to mention the fear of having cancer
and unsure what to do so at a very
minimum you want to be doing 16 hours of
fasting and have a eight hour eating
window and when you eat you want to do
low carb so the ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting is the best way to
prevent cancer because that's going to
prevent the damage in the mitochondria
all right so what do you do if you have
cancer well
you want to do regular fasting but you
want to step it up to at least 18 hours
fasting with a six-hour eating window
and if you could i would do more than
that i would do like a 20-hour fasting
with a four-hour eating window or even
do omad where you're eating one meal a
day now in addition to that i would do
weekly
fasting for two days it's four to eight
hours very very important every week if
you can't do
two days of fasting then do two days of
500 calories now
to me that's going to be a lot more
difficult because you haven't really
adapted to that and you're just lowering
calories and if you eat just a little
bit you're going to be more hungry but
it has been shown that a calorie
restrictive diet
can actually be very beneficial to
help someone with cancer all right then
once a month i would recommend fasting
for at least
four days but
i would recommend going up to seven days
if possible that's once a month and then
when you eat the main dish
should be
cruciferous vegetables okay and a lot of
them and so maybe your meal would have a
base of broccoli or maybe it would be
kale or cabbage or cauliflower and
there's a lot of different great recipes
that you can make with this base of
cruciferous now why would you recommend
cruciferous number one it's low in
protein number two it's low in fat it's
low in carbs it has huge anti-cancer
properties it also has anti-angiogenic
what's that that is a property that
helps to start off the cancer of its
blood vessels okay so thing i haven't
talked about but it's it can help with
that because if the cancer cells can't
get a blood supply they die and
cruciferous also help increase phase 1
phase 2 detoxification of your liver
helping to minimize carcinogens so i
would recommend about 10 cups okay per
day now if you're doing omad one meal a
day that would just be 10 cups in that
one meal now as a side dish you would
want to have low protein okay not high
protein so maybe it's like three ounces
of protein the type of protein i would
recommend would be
protein high in omega-3 fatty fish
sardines
you know even cod liver things like that
omega-3 fatty acids are very very very
beneficial when someone has cancer now
as far as fat goes olive oil would be
probably one of the best fats that you
can consume it has
wonderful anti-cancer properties in cod
liver oil being omega-3 apparently even
though it's a fat won't turn into
ketones and won't feed the cancer the
raw material for its membranes now if
you can add cruciferous sprouts as in
broccoli sprouts you'll have even a more
potent effect on this cancer and of
course you want to avoid cheese and soy
and conventional foods that have
pesticides you want to do mainly organic
now of course i'm just telling you the
ideal situation okay not everyone is
going to be able to eat this way now the
main reason why we are doing this study
is to figure out what we can do to not
only enhance the benefits of fasting but
also to come up with a method of
blocking
this chemical pathway this door called
scott which would really be beneficial
for those people who just cannot do
fasting whether they're too thin or
they're too frail or they just can't do
it we're trying to find out the results
of what would happen if someone didn't
fast and just did these nutritional
protocols but i think ideally if you did
fasting and these nutritional protocols
would really be a very good strategy
last thing i want to mention is
unfortunately the success rate the
effectiveness of chemo and radiation are
very very very minimal
but i want to emphasize the prevention
of cancer is the most important thing
you can do right now if you're new to my
channel
and you want to learn how to do healthy
keto in infesting i have a very short
playlist right here
check it out
you